japan's government has announced it's
going to dump contaminated water from
the fukushima
nuclear power plant into the pacific
ocean more than a million tons will be
released this way
the process will only begin in two years
time and is expected to take decades to
complete as the water
will be filtered and diluted to safe
levels first
the move though has already provoked
anger from neighboring countries
despite doubts and opposition from home
and abroad japan has unilaterally
decided to release the fukushima nuclear
wastewater
into the sea before exhausting all safe
ways of disposal
and without fully consulting with
neighboring countries and the
international community
this is highly irresponsible and will
severely affect human health
and the immediate interests of people in
neighboring countries
the japanese government's decision is
absolutely unacceptable
the decision to release the fukushima
tank water into the sea not only
threatens the safety of neighboring
countries and the marine environment
but also as a measure unilaterally
decided without sufficient discussion
and agreement with our country
which is the nearest neighboring country
well disaster at the fukushima nuclear
power plant struck back in march of 2011
when a powerful earthquake hit japan's
east coast that led to a
massive tsunami which triggered one of
the worst nuclear disasters
on record so far the plant hasn't been
completely
decontaminated though the government's
plans to tackle the issue
have caught some flack including at home
people have rallied outside the prime
minister's office calling on the
government to reverse its decision
among those strongly opposed to tokyo's
plans to dump waste water into the sea
is the japanese fishing industry
which fears of trace radioactivity
contaminating fish
and ending up on people's plates
i'm in shock i'm originally from
fukushima and so i think i feel it more
i'm very shocked i do not wish at all
for it to be released into the sea
when the disaster happened you had to
act to treat the area through
decontamination
but then don't foolishly spread the
contamination further after the disaster
people buy seafood products to eat and
some products they eat raw without
cooking or processing
these raw products will become very
dangerous as japan dumps nuclear
wastewater into the sea
japan's decision hit is hard our
business has already hit rock bottom due
to the covet 19 pandemic
and we are struggling to survive every
day this will be true even more so if we
suffer this double whammy
we used to often buy squid to it but now
we only buy a little
if the nuclear wastewater is discharged
into the sea
then not only japanese products but also
our south korean products
will be affected i thought that sickens
me
i think the government should strongly
protest against japan
you